we've got um this combination of
much higher inflation the obr i think
inflation might be its highest level for
30 years
um big tax rises don't forget they
weren't announced yesterday but earlier
this year we've had very very big tax
increases
announced and wages rising relatively
gradually so that means probably that in
a year's time someone on average
earnings will be a bit less well-off
than they are today and that's not
obviously conducive to a feel-good
factor if you're
if you're actually feeling worse off
let's talk about universal credit
do you think this taper offsets the loss
of money from um
cutting that 20 20-pound off uplift
well it does if you are working
full-time um on the minimum wage or on
relatively low earnings and for most
people in that situation they're going
to be gaining a thousand pounds
a year or more from the reduction in the
taper so that does offset the
uh the 20 pounds a week cut if however
you are on universal credit and out of
work so if you're unemployed or disabled
for example
then this doesn't help you at all and
this is really part of quite a long term
and very long term
it's a rebalancing of our welfare system
which um supports people in work
but increasingly is really quite mean to
people who are out of work
you said that the policy choices were
unrelated to the pandemic how can we
have a budget which for all intents and
purposes is being delivered while we're
still in the pandemic with policy policy
choices that are unrelated to the
pandemic i think the point is that the
um
spending increases that were announced
were always going to be necessary
pandemic or no pandemic so the long term
rate of increase for nhs spending was in
the short run it's getting more than it
might have done in the long run there's
no more there than we otherwise would
have had and the increases on things
like schools and the justice system and
prisons and so on everyone could see
that those were necessary again pandemic
or no pandemic so those spending
increases i think would have happened in
the medium run
anyway and the tax rises um were there
to pay for for that and in particular to
pay for the increased health
spending i mean to be honest these are
changes that we have said for quite a
number of years now we're eventually
going to be inevitable and i think what
we've had really is the chancellor
taking the opportunity of the pandemic
to introduce these these changes which i
think were pretty hard to avoid in any
case
talking of taxes there were no green
taxes that were announced were you
surprised by that
not terribly surprised because we
haven't had much in the way of green
taxes um for uh some time don't forget
and this is the 12th year in a row that
fuel duties have been
frozen i don't think there was any um
likelihood that we were going to get a
tax on gas consumption at home for
example not least because of very high
increases in gas prices and don't forget
that's what you know what would green
taxes mean well the two big things they
would mean would be an increase in the
cost of
heating your home with gas
and an increase in the cost of driving
now
it's not in the least bit surprising
that for political reasons that's not
likely to happen
so if you look at the reductions in air
passenger duty and that fuel duty freeze
that you were talking about do you think
that will actively contribute to
actually more carbon being emitted
well making making driving cheaper than
it otherwise would have been and driving
in particular petrol and diesel cars
will have a small effect um in that
direction i think the apd
duty changes for various technical
reasons probably won't make much
difference at all
um so yes possibly a small
negative impact
there but but really very small relative
to
the sorts of things the government's
doing elsewhere outside of the tax
system so
you know big big increases in green
electricity over the last
decade and you know we are genuinely
moving to
electric um vehicles we'll have to all
new cars will have to be electric by
2030. so i wouldn't overstate the
consequences of not having green taxes i
think for
understandable reasons the government is
using a different set of tools to get us
there
in some of these instances that's still
going to be very very hard how we move
away from gas eating despite some of the
money that's been allocated for example
to air source heat pumps i think is is
still very uncertain
let's talk about alcohol the
simplification simplification of the
alcohol duty system um it was announced
but do you think people are actually
going to feel that in the pub
well the um the the changes for most
rates will be relatively
small i mean there will be some
reasonably significant increases in for
example the cost of strong
uh stronger red wines there'll be some
reasonably significant reductions in the
cost of sparkling
uh wines not too much i mean not not
enough difference i think uh
in the um in the duty on most beers to
for people in the pub to see a great
deal of difference i mean what we have
to me i mean what the chancellor is
doing i think is is long overdue i mean
we've long had a system which uh taxes
um
alcohol at very different rates which
effectively encouraged people uh to
consume stronger drinks with uh more
alcohol in them relative to drinks with
less alcohol in them and it will remain
the case that if you want to um you know
if you want to drink too much and not
pay much to the tax man then then stick
to cider which has always been the case
and rather strangely will remain the
case under this new system
you open your comments this morning by
saying it was a once in a decade event
why did you think
that paul
i think if we look over this year we've
had this huge increase in taxes 40
billion pounds we've also had this very
big increase in
spending and that's after
the long period of spending cuts that we
saw under the coalition and conservative
governments i think this this year has
seen this acknowledgement that we're in
a new world where um the state is just
going to be a bit bigger than it's been
in the past and acknowledgement that we
we're spending more on the health
service because that's clearly what is
demanded by the population and an
acknowledgement that more is needed for
a number of other public services i
think that sets this budget alongside if
for example george osborne's george
osborne's first one where he set out the
path to austerity or one of gordon
brown's early ones where you saw um
taxes and spending uh set up increases
set out there i think this is resetting
uh fiscal policy
in you
in quite a big way